good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday I'm
sure you didn't realize because you
haven't left your house in two weeks but
it is Wednesday hump day a favorite day
of ours here at the Morning Joe so feel
free to hump with whoever you're
quarantined but don't leave the house to
hump someone please it usually as a
favorite day because it usually means
Theo's here cuz you're gonna hump him
yeah but Theodore fátima and doctor foul
Iman is not here well is that the first
time we've put that together hmm oh no
I've been saying it for a few days I
guess I maybe I did but they're so
similar that you might not realize what
I'm saying but he is part of the White
House Task Force you might have heard of
him dr. couch Iman and we miss him
dearly and do you want to explain your
your reasoning for bringing the Fed
Chairman I told everyone the field
wasn't really feeling very good
yesterday and honestly as the day
progressed he got worse which was really
freaking me out he was very lethargic he
peed in the elevator which he never does
like we took him out to pee and hadn't
even been that long since his last paid
so he was just feeling a little
disoriented but he pretty much rested
the whole day and last night he was
feeling his spirits were so much higher
worrying more energetic more excited to
eat like I knew that he was feeling
better when I was eating in my bed and
he was like sniffing around trying to
eat like when he wasn't doing that I was
really worried about eating just some
pasta and cottage cheese which is like a
weird thing that I eat it's weird
because her family did it's actually a
Jewish dish yes when I went to so good
you guys yeah it's just you can make
regular noodles I was using me and Ben
we're like the last people at the
grocery store so the only pasta shape
left was tiny tiny tiny penne
like literally two inch penne it's cute
but it's very hard to get on the fork
usually with a big penne you just stick
the spool thing right maybe you need a
spoon
maybe yeah so you just boil it up a
little salt and then you put cottage
cheese on and I like using cold cottage
cheese because the mixing of the cold
and the very hot pasta is lovely you
guys it's so good I feel like there's
gonna be so many people could think it's
what I've heard of this but like we both
love it it's such a good day I think how
did she's like it wouldn't be
theoretically the most disgusting thing
on planet earth one of the scariest
foods of all time
it depends what brand because I am
Breakstone through and through eight
stone forever but we're limited
you know it's our options and I got um
Daisy like dollop of Daisy they can make
cream cottage cheese and it's it's
pretty gross it's really Kirti like it's
so
Kirti yeah it's I don't recommend it
courier but it gets the job done you
know a lot of people our ancestors back
in Poland um they used to put cinnamon
in it as well and that I think is where
I draw the line okay but I encourage
everyone to try it it's really good and
I'm like a freak I eat like a
two-year-old like you know like you're
always eating your fish in your salad
like I literally cannot eat anything
that's not chicken or french fries and
you would think I would die at the site
I hate cheese I hate milk you think I
would die occurred I hate oh I ain't
currants you think I would die at the
sight of cottage cheese and normally I
do but with pasta it's tolerable and
it's really really good it's good
everyone if like you're feeling really
boarding just want to cook something
which is exactly what I've been doing um
not only have I cracked and got a
peloton and I'm jumping around in my
apartment but like I have started
legitimately cooking I had groceries
come the other day I saw you made a
chowder
I made a chowder yet last night I made a
mushroom pasta at a gym maleeni pasta so
are these that okay hello fresh that was
a home chef yes um but I'm also just
like cooking on my own I even got the
ingredients to make a vegetarian chili
because once I now that I'm cooking I
made hard-boiled eggs so that I could
have a healthy snack in my house well
why don't you if you're cooking it why
don't you get kosher meat and make a
kosher meat chili there is no more
kosher meat available by the way the
Jews really went and got it all or
people got desperate and just bought
kosher no because literally every
grocery store does not have an ounce of
kosher meat oh yeah look at my I'm
brooding I'm an iron deficiency
I have no kosher meat I even tried to
get beyond me instead to do with that
but the order didn't come through
because it was sold out and you know I'm
gonna be making a bean chili okay that's
like one out of two toilets now that I'm
cooking in my house which I you guys
know I couldn't even make a grilled
cheese which I'm still struggling with
but now I'm like oh my god I can eat
whatever I want to make it for myself
what do I want so I got the ingredients
for chili which is my favorite food and
for meatballs but then I didn't get any
of the ground meat that I ordered so I
don't know how that's gonna work no to
be honest I'm pretty sure Olivia Oscar
is responsible for the nationwide kosher
meat it meat outed she literally has it
all did you see that thing of taco meat
that she had well there are people in
her defense she made some for me and
lets it
her doorman but Ben didn't want to walk
over and pick it up so I told her she
could take it back so half of it was for
me like I want to go to her house for
dinner every single night but because
she's pregnant like I just won't take
the food from him Craig good risk no
[ __ ] that no look I don't want to go
outside and then bring it maybe
something into her house yes of course
if she gets sick like it could be bad
you know god forbid
so I'm not worried about taking pregnant
listen the two of them eat good like I'm
not worried about that
they eat good and if you're curious as
to what she makes and how she makes it
she did a patreon cooking video for us
there's a drama this weekend and it's so
good I was editing it for her and I
learned so much from and it really got
me inspired to cook so like you have you
seen that mean that's going around
that's like half of us are gonna emerge
from this as like top chefs and half are
going to emerge as alcoholics yeah I am
one of those people who like this has
taught me how to cook and now I will be
cooking forever and also it's just like
something to do that it passes the time
it's something to do so that was my vibe
yesterday but I don't have a stove or an
oven working so I went the alcoholic
route and I had four glasses of wine and
I finished this large bottle of wine and
I feel like I'm becoming like a wino and
I'm like living for it I usually don't
like to drink wine but I just think
drinking tequila in my house it's like a
dangerous precedent to set unless I'm
having company you know but she's like I
know Tuesday me and Ben like it's
dangerous and I had my scattegories game
and I know it said yesterday my
scattegories game when I played two
nights ago over zoom was really not that
fun and it wasn't like it was really
frustrating with the sound and the Wi-Fi
but with four glasses of wine it was a
blast like I won two nights in a row
yeah and I beat my best score 24 I went
to 29 and it was good it was better so
it just makes I know it's sad but
looking makes things more enjoyable in
quarantine I know I was actually talking
to snitch last night and I was like
losing my mind a little bit and I was
like maybe I should just have a drink
and me I might have a drink today
because I don't want to feel like [ __ ]
like I don't want to be hungover but
like one or two glasses of wine like I
should be okay you know what I did I
drank at seven and I was done drinking
by like 9:30 yeah and then I took two
advil drink a bottled water watch my
from pearls and what about interesting
well we'll see you know but I'm getting
desperate I've now downloaded so many
games on my phone but I like the
interactive games where I could play
with my Facebook friends so I downloaded
words from friend where's the friends
I'm playing I think I'm playing with
Olivia I'm like almost a hundred percent
sure that she's cheating because I'm not
very good but she's a little too good
and I'm playing with my friends Nicki
and Margie and then I also downloaded
draw something do you have that app yeah
I think you would love
well you know what I'm already spending
more time on my phone just because
that's what we're doing and my wrist
hurts a lot when I go to bed at night my
wrists like I'm getting really bad
carpal tunnel so I can't do anything
that's gonna make me spend more time on
my phone I'm spending the most time ever
on my phone but I've been reading little
fires everywhere and like it's taking me
so long but I'm finally at around 50%
and it's it's picking enjoying it um not
yet but I know that I'm about to because
it's about to move full steam ahead and
that's what everyone had said like the
beginning is like really boring and hard
to get into but then it starts to move
along and I think the new episodes drop
today I think three new episodes on Hulu
don't quote me on that but I'm pretty
sure very exciting I also uh I don't
watch that much TV yesterday I watched a
new Vanderpump rules which I just like I
know like I'm dying for new stuff to
come out but I was just like yeah I was
not in the mood like to go on input 1 2
input 2 back to cable like no I haven't
been on cable in two weeks like all
about the inputs it's all about input 3
for me oh no sorry input 2 is my fire
stick yeah oh and now that I'm spending
so much time like I'm hating my fire
stick literally it's so so I guess I've
had it for like three years and maybe
it's time for anyone like I might steal
the Apple TV and the brand-new one that
we got for the office because like in my
bedroom I cannot deal with the fire
stick so [ __ ] slow yes like literally
to open Netflix I could go get a snack
and come back and it would still be
loading oh that's annoying I don't have
a problem it's a big problem damn I'm
sorry to hear that um yeah I agree
Vanderpump rules it was just like I
couldn't be bothered to be to care I'm
desperate for content but maybe next
week we'll see how I feel yeah but I
watched sleep over which was ever where
there was a lot of drama with the
selection so much drama because Jackie
and I couldn't really decide yesterday
so we put it to a poll on our Instagram
story should we go a superstar or the
laundromat and everyone voted for
Superstar but then I found out literally
two days ago
Netflix took Superstar off of Netflix
like how dare they justice for Mary
Katherine Gallagher so we were left with
just you know by default the laundromat
and we put it up and literally within a
minute there was 30 comments every
single one was like this was the worst
movie I ever saw worse maybe I ever saw
and Jackie and I hadn't seen it it did
look somewhat interesting but we did
want to take the risk of like people not
trusting us so we changed it last-minute
to something we had recently been
talking about which was sleepover with
Alexis it was an inspired choice I'm so
glad to talk about it there are so many
different layers I have so many no there
are so many layers and I just we need to
get into it that
star studded the cast and another layer
being that I didn't hate it like I was
nobody day ages well I was saying like I
was nervous to rewatch ah it holds us
dance the test of time I mean it's
literally I don't know what came out
first that or New York minute I think
sleepover but they're literally the same
formula for a movie I know I thought
Eugene Levy was about to step out of the
patrol tech car it was just the same
thing like fake cop you know chasing
down these hooligans like it was so
silly but it was so fabulous so fabulous
okay we'll get into it but you know
without further ado I think it's time
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and it's
time but just very briefly you know
don't want to step on your toes cuz I
know you're really busy but like my
shoes are white so that would be so
embarrassing if there was like foot
prints on that really would be so I
would be really quick these shoes like
really trigger people I'm aware but I
think they're fabulous you know what I
actually just ordered a new pair of
fancy white flats that I can wear for
spring/summer because I just like to
wear a little flat in the summer you
know I think they're fabulous and so
hopefully like people will be okay with
them but I understand like people don't
understand my grandmother shoes but I'm
paying homage to the nurse's out there
and it's what you're doing it's
important to do that and my sweatshirts
from brown tied girl um today's episode
is brought to you by Squarespace they've
got it all in one domains websites
online stores marketing tools and more
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools in analytics Squarespace
is the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence to run your
business you can create beautiful
websites to turn your cool idea into a
new website showcase your work bloggers
published content sub products and
services of all kinds or promote your
physical or online business they
Squarespace helps you by giving you
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online they have the
ability to customize look and feel
settings products and more with just a
few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and it's a new way to buy
domains and choose from over 200
extensions so Squarespace actually
helped us secure a domain for camp
choice calm because someone had it which
like how dare they um so they really do
everything you can build your website
and I feel like now such a great time to
like start your passion project why not
you have so much time like why not be
productive you want to start a blog you
have something you've been dying to do
start a website and Squarespace can do
pretty much everything you can pick and
choose templates settings colors you
wanna have a plenty vibe what
it is and I think that everyone would
really enjoy it so if you want to start
your business
get started today this is this is the
kick in the ass that you need go to
squarespace.com slash toast for a free
trial and then when you're ready to
launch a website use the offer code
toast to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain so that
link is squarespace.com slash toast for
the free trial and then when you're
ready to launch use the offer code toast
to save 10% on your first purchase thank
you sir sign on get a website ok first
story a little celeb coronavirus news
Prince Charles has tested positive for
Kona virus this is really crazy because
he's 71 Prince Charles the 71 year old
heir to the British throne that never
that's not weird saying yes 70 year old
Prince yeah as tested
yes we're Leah's like the same royal
standing as George yeah has tested
positive for the corona virus and his
self isolating with quote mild symptoms
his Clarence House Office announced on
Wednesday the Prince of Wales is wife
Camilla 72 the Duchess of Cornwall has
tested negative for koban 19 the to our
self isolating at their home Burnham on
the Balmoral estate in Scotland quote he
has displaying my he has been displaying
mild symptoms but otherwise remains in
good health and has been working from
home throughout the last one day from
home what the hell does he do as usual
he's a blog well I mean does he use
Squarespace to accomplish shows he'd
first sure does but his job is just like
being a public and so like maybe he just
walks around his living room like
shaking hand you know by the way if your
job is to be in the public you literally
can't work from home yeah this is just
interesting to me tell me what you think
about he him having coronavirus and he's
been quarantined with Camille and her
not having currently oh I feel like
there was not one smooch in the last
week so I feel like this is like a funny
thing where it's like if someone's
quarantined with like their husband and
like one of them gets current a virus
and the other doesn't like they will
everyone will know that like you and
your husband don't have sex you know
yeah or even like touch or use the same
surfaces yeah or I mean honestly me and
Ben have been so separate like it's very
possible that I could have current of
hours in bed with it because because of
my back I'm being so annoying like then
wants absolutely nothing to do with me
and he's been in the living room
literally until 10 p.m. last night yeah
no it's possible but like in the total
of our quarantine like 100 percent I
would have gotten it maybe yesterday I
wouldn't have heard right hey I won't
but like and that's really crazy I know
what's going on in the marriage should
also I feel like when you have such a
big house when you have a castle and
like you're old and I feel like by the
time I'm 70 like get the [ __ ] out of my
face hell yeah I'm gonna be ready for my
own bed yeah I feel that like a hundred
you know what I respect this yeah and if
you have the means to like have two
master suites why not yeah and actually
the king and the queen do sleep in
separate beds I believe Wow provincial
yeah that's what they do on the crown um
this this I honestly like it's just a
sounding better and better to me I know
to be a queen this quarantine is really
making me realize like how jealous I am
of people's homes you know I went on us
is what I've been saying I was watching
Kaylee Dickerson's Instagram story she's
been like updating everyone they Laurie
built a house from scratch like it was
this old old house and they totally like
renovated it for the last year and like
now's the perfect time because it's
pretty much I come together and just
like seeing her bathroom like I wanted I
like it so today the size of my whole
apartment like and they have this huge
island but like seven bars so I was like
I need a house I mean I can't even fit
all my groceries in my kitchen cabinet
oh really all I'm the table all my
groceries are on the counter it's so
hard ya know seeing some of the country
stars they're really like digging it
because they also have like ice the farm
tremens vibe that Nikko Hawking and Luke
Holmes I totally they're at home gym but
they don't give us that much like tour
vibe like I got a full tour from the
Dickerson's oh oh that's nice no but
like Nico and Luke like know how to
catch a vibe in their backyard with
their [ __ ] fire pit and like their
land I'm so upset that like I don't live
in Nashville I'm so upset that like we
didn't get a farm come in like before
this and you know what's so upsetting
it's like we're living at our this at
the same price as like what a mansion in
Nashville like I need a mansion in
Nashville yeah I feel like honestly this
is putting a lot of things into
perspective for a lot of people you know
people are coming together people are
realizing the importance of self-care
and staying at home and like you know
what's important in life and like this
has taught me more than ever that like I
need to get out of the city I need to
get into a farm Chaman but at the same
time it is also like really showing me
how great it is to live in New York
because I been has been walking theö
three or four times a day and any time
it goes out we live right by Duane Reade
I'm like I need icy hot I need Tylenol
like what if idea what if we lived in a
suburb but you can't just walk to Duane
Reade
no you would like get a car you would
plan better and you would have those
things yeah and I would have a bigger
house to put all my icy hot snow I can
only buy two boxes at a time and there's
only four in a box and you know what
else that
Tina's making me realize like I know we
always say no to life and like there's
nothing that I love more than like
staying home but I but I think there are
some days where my regular day life and
my quarantine life are too similar I
couldn't agree more we always say H was
roasting me last night saying how my
life is no different right now and I was
like that's not true I don't get home at
noon no everyday by the way we've spoken
about this on our patreon and if you're
ever interested in more like what goes
on behind the scenes of the toast you
can head over to patreon.com slash
morning toast but with our schedule
being so flexible like there are days
when we're doing the show even million
podcast record we have meetings and like
we really don't get home until eight
five six o'clock but then there's like a
slow day where like after the show we'll
only have like one or two meetings or
we'll just record a patron and we are
home by like two o'clock but then we've
so much work to do at two o'clock that I
work from like 2 to 11
yeah but I'm working from my bed yes
yeah so there are a lot of similarities
in some days as the morning toast toast
and a quarantine day but something about
being forced to be home and being forced
to be with my husband like that's making
me go insane and I don't forget who I
was having this comfort oh I was talking
to Kristen last night what are you gonna
do on the first night back like what
what vibe are you trying to catch oh I'm
trying to catch an alfresco sound chair
a vibe I want like a daytime drinking
like maybe watch a sunset sunset cruise
maybe we hit up surf Lodge go to Montauk
get a house like oh my god I love that
idea
though like Montauk is so secluded
that's like very much like wood I feel
like I would have you know flashbacks to
the quarantine oh that's true okay so
like I don't know up see me get me maybe
rent a farm time and maybe we go to Utah
like I'm just trying to let say hatch a
[ __ ] bye so let's say that the
quarantine ends on Thursday I'm so down
to fly the trips and Caicos with you
Friday for the next month but on
Thursday night like I'm going to a
restaurant I'm gonna go to the busiest
most packed restaurant and I'm gonna get
the tiniest table with all my friends
and I'm literally gonna sweat and lick
them and then I'm gonna go to the pet
most packed club and get the smallest
table all the way in the middle and I'm
gonna rage till the break of dawn yeah I
love that for you look I want to be
rubbed up you don't know what to do I'm
gonna take the subway at rush hour
that's how much I'm craving human
contact yeah I just want someone to
grope me on the train okay is that so
much to ask no I think that'll come your
way oh my god you know it's getting to
me like for sure I cracked I have so
cracked and
Gretchen wieners cracked yep I mean uh
what took was what day are we 30 day 13
and Quarantine day 13 overall teens for
quarantine oh also can we just talk
about some of the reception from our
gonna be with dr. Debra Berg oh for sure
we were really proud of ourselves when
we wrapped it up but you know people are
so like critical critical and even
though we thought it was great like
someone could have something bad to say
and to be honest I don't want to jinx it
but I have not seen one mean comment
about it like people were just really
happy that we didn't like making into a
joke which we obviously would never do
but we have to get our little sass in
there with our scarves I think one of
the nicest compliments I've seen is like
that we were so professional but we were
still ourselves and like we made it our
own yeah I'm really proud and to be
honest the video is like reaching people
I never thought it would reach like
people who don't understand what I do
like adults you know who are like
reaching out to me and Ben being like
wow what a fabulous interview I got so
many texts about it
Ben's dad text me that he watched it and
Ben's dad never curse and he said it was
[ __ ] amazing
Wow yeah you know that's how you know
wow that's really key I like I said he
watched it and then he watched it again
oh my god I love him honestly I just
take me back like I live 11 quarantine
days for just obviously I miss her doing
she misses us ya know I miss like when
she was here in the room yeah and I'm
living for like the press you know like
people are really respecting us like we
were written up in CNN today respecting
us I never would have thought if there
was only one place that wrote it up it
would be CNN it's our counterpart chance
CNN writing up tiene right and we see
each other we see each other love news
networks that's something also speaking
of tienen there's tons of new episodes
new episode of the Sinatra she did a
solo episode I'm in a new episode with
of caviar dreams with Margot Joseph's
she had such an interesting guest she
had Dorothy who is the executive
producer of Real Housewives of New
Jersey and they were just talking about
how she like became like a female in
reality TV and it's fabulous so I'm
insane until there's a new episode of
mood coming out today amazing
well we're praying for Prince Charles um
his symptoms are mild so I hope that he
is okay you know but you know he is old
so I just generally hold knee at-risk
group if he doesn't any pre-existing
medical conditions I think that that'll
be he might be okay
but you never know so just everyone
cross your fingers
we that the crown has like excellent
medical care the best I mean like King
Prince I mean the hundreds of your old
Prince Ingrid's us what's-his-name
you know Phillip Phillip oh yeah no he's
a corpse look if he's still alive he's a
testament to modern medicine yeah you
know so he's truly the definition of
weekend at Bernie's let me just prop him
he said it you said it okay
next sorry one more thing about the
quarantine like not having nail polish
on like I've never had so much dirt
under my fingernails it's so disgusting
like and I wash my hands a million times
a day and I clean out my nails and I
don't know how to stop getting like dirt
I'm like a child who was like playing in
the playground and is dirt under their
fingernails yes I discussed it there's
nothing rosier than that
you just got to trim them down so
there's not enough space for the dirt
that's a great idea yeah you know what
this has an opportunity to really grow
my nail I think I'm gonna try and get an
at-home waxing kit from Amazon Oh God I
wonder backs between my eyebrows and
then maybe my armpits honestly just
don't why like those things never work
the way you want them to I bel finally a
good test spot like I had nothing but
time never a trick makes the perfect
blend of wax like so tokus pocus do you
hello Adam ray okay on tick tock I do
not you might have seen his videos he
has this character Rosa and he wears a
towel yeah eyelashes I love him like I
love him so much and he just did a
collab with James Charles who's actually
really turning out premium content
during the quarantine I have to respect
it and he had atom rayon and he gave
Rosa a makeover cuz she's always wearing
like ratchet ass makeup and you got to
know like the atom behind Rosa and it
was such a good video and I thought
James did actually a really good job of
interviewing him and not making it about
himself because this guy Adams just so
interesting he only has 29 videos on
tick-tock and he literally has four
million followers and it's like renowned
worldwide and he just comes something
with the blog squad and at the end of
the interview James was like all this
stuff is happening for you like what
like what's your dream like what he want
to do with this like what's the best
part of it and he literally had the
sweetest answer he was like honestly
like I just can't believe that people
know who I am and I'm just so proud to
like be doing this and representing my
community in like a positive way I
delivery was gonna start crying he's so
[ __ ] cute it's a really good video if
you're obsessed with him on tik-tok he
does the DeRosa videos
dude come here dude you have a dollar
it's so good he did a video James
Charles is fabulous I'm really turning
into like a teenager with my content but
I sometimes get home and I just can't
turn on the TV
like I just can't the idea of watching
more TV makes me want to die mm-hmm it's
tough it's tough out there but speaking
of interviews where people can't help
making it about themselves Miley Cyrus
is live show I thought you were just
about to like insolvent no no no I know
I turned on for two minutes because she
had a guest on and she was talking about
herself the entire time like telling
stories about her childhood and it's
like so why'd you bring in guest on yeah
she did that I watched hers with Billy
Ray and she literally couldn't get a
word in Billy Ray was not something she
was the guest and he was preach preach
preach preach preach like literally was
speaking in inspirational quotes it was
so frustrating to watch and you got to
see like a little sneak of his house and
on the wall he like a huge signed
Platinum Old Town Road Thicke yeah yeah
but still like nobody asked for these
Instagram eyes you guys yeah no I like
the Instagram lives of people just like
chillin like Joe Jonas did one yesterday
did you know he's like a full DJ he did
like a full set like with the equipment
I was so impressed like that somebody
like when he goes live with Sophie and
they're being cute and funny like I like
people in their house I did one with Ben
last night you know who joined Donnie
Wahlberg fabulous I got some good blue
bloods in sight
I like the casual live but like the
formal live show she's turning into the
toast oh yeah that's agreed social
there's a difference
I'm not here for any of it but
especially not with social card sheet
keep stirring talk about how she turned
her glam room into an extra space and
how important it is to change your
spaces like well I don't have a space no
I like the idea of people going live
like I like to see what people's houses
look like I'm really enjoying the Sophie
and Joe Jonas content but like the
pre-recorded like with the with the
slate like I'm not into the whole
production like just go out for any fun
and chill you know yeah okay next up
Lady gaga delays new album release amid
coronavirus pandemic this is something
we were talking about yesterday but now
that Lady Gaga has done it I have
different thoughts I'm really upset Lady
Gaga's postponing the release of her
upcoming sixth studio album chromatic I
remember when I said that was never
gonna be the name in a million [ __ ]
years and I was wrong amid the corona
virus pandemic quote I wanted to tell
you that after a lot of deliberation
I've made the incredibly tough decision
to postpone the release of chromatic ax
I will announce a new 2020 release date
soon the singer explained that while art
is something I can help in a time like
this she doesn't feel right about
releasing her album as the virus
continues to spread quote this is such a
hectic and scary time for all of us and
while I believe art is one of the
strongest things we have to provide joy
and he
to each other during times like this it
just doesn't feel right to me to release
this album with all that is going on
right now during the global pandemic so
lame I mean I said once I'll say it
again like this is lame
I don't know here's the thing I agree
but like I don't want the Lady Gaga
album to come out right now because like
I'm not ready for it and whenever a new
album comes out like and I listen to it
a lot it becomes a reminder of a certain
time in my life and then like if I
listen to the album in a year from now
I'll just be reminded of being in
quarantine like cracking left right in
center that's so true actually like I'm
so excited for this album stupid love is
such an incredible song I feel like
these are gonna be the bops of summer
and like I don't want to listen to them
in my house and if she puts the album
out I'm gonna line up listening to it
and like just wanting to like break my
window so when you listen to the Born
This Way album what place in your life
does it take you freshman year of
college and also this summer before that
the summer before that is what it
reminds me of like we have listened to
it all the time at camp yeah that's so
true I never really associated like how
for like big albums that I listen to
from track 1 to track 12 straight
through and yet on repeat it takes me
back to a certain place and I don't want
to be brought back back to this place
that's a very interesting outlook to me
I just think it's like lame because I
feel like whether they say it or not
like the motive has a lot to do with
money for sure and I sent you an article
yeah that streaming music streaming
numbers are actually downs like the
quarantine data was released yeah you
would think that people are listening to
more music because all we have is time
but they're actually not data has been
released that streams have dropped a
sizable 7 / 6 / seven point six percent
to under 20 billion I mean if you think
about it it's people really listen to
music I mean I have a listen to music
once except last night I turned on Kacey
Musgraves and I was trying to get drunk
but like people listen to music on
commutes they don't have commutes what
else do people listen to music at
parties they're not having parties clubs
like it actually makes sense even though
you would think people like are now
looking for music more than ever music
honestly is not stimulating enough yeah
and you know what people are saying like
check out a podcast bah bah bah but
we're looking at our numbers and like we
have video and audio so it's different
but a lot of people who used to listen
on audio are now watching on video
you know our podcast numbers have
definitely dropped what our video
numbers have increased yeah that's
because like people listen to podcast
when they're commuting when they're at
work and they're not doing
that literally just proves the streaming
the this data yeah people aren't looking
for audio content they need something
more stimulating yeah
it's crazy subscribe to us on YouTube
also but then it's like I appreciate an
album like I'm still listening to music
and when I'm listening she now is Kelsea
Ballerini album but her album is perfect
for quarantine yes it depends on the
genre and album call chromatic ax isn't
with a lead single that stupid love is
not perfect for Corinne I agree like
that's really very well said Kelsea
Ballerini x' album really is perfect for
quarantine like a glass of wine happy to
get a phenomenally town that song is so
good it's so good man envenom down it's
just so good so anyways even though we
were like hard on Haim I'm actually
grateful to Lady Gaga for this decision
yeah I agree I could really use a new
Kasey Musgraves album right now like
that is the totally the vibe yeah I can
also really like I really wish I smoked
pot like I just feel like if I smoked
pot like this would be my week yeah
that's how don't get hung over yeah
that's how I feel about like needing a
prescription for an X right now yeah
well I did get a prescription for muscle
relaxers and they're genuinely nothing
of the sort
like I they're they're not strong enough
for me like I recreationally I just
don't feel like they're what I need I
need more yeah someone commented those
of us working from home are watching
shows while we work rather than
listening to podcasts totally because no
one's uh-oh
no one's over your shoulder because what
are you doing and that's why so many
more people are watching the toast and
my friends who are toasters and listen
every single day they listen as a
podcast and I'm always like you should
watch on the show and they're like yeah
sure whatever
but now they're watching and they're
like oh my god this is so premium it's
so much better and I think that's why
people were shocked at the deborah birx
interview they were like this quality
I'm like [ __ ] we do this [ __ ]
quality every single day yeah and then
understand that some people can't watch
while they're at work every single day
but if you can you totally should be
because it's everything of the sort and
we work really hard to make this cream
everything I'm this sore so make sure
you're subscribed okay
next story is brought to you by
something really important and I think
you have a song about it I have a few
songs so okay is it about a DNA test so
it is it is about doctor foul Chipman is
that doctor pouch Eamon okay
so here's what happens this is a brand
called embark it's a dogs DNA test kit
it's the most genius thing ever
whether you have a new pup or an old
friend an embark breed and health test
kit is the exact key to unlocking your
dog's unique breed mix and genetically
informed health needs so you can help
your pup live its healthiest happiest
life from breech 8 breathe trades to
genetic risk factors for health
conditions embark provides the resources
to help you when your vet best tailor
care for your dog specific needs you can
get to know your pup every year millions
of dogs are rescued from shelters and
while we know we love them there's a lot
that we don't know about them with an
embark DNA test kit you'll finally have
an answer the next time someone stops
you and says what kind of dog is this I
did this for Theo first of all the
process was so easy literally they mail
you this little box and has a q-tip in
it Felix the q-tip put it as cheek
pouches you put it back in the box
there's a prepaid label and then
literally a few weeks later I got a text
text and they were like he just took a
DNA test
turns out he's a hundred percent Russian
even when easly in country so yeah he's
got health problems that's the puppy in
him
bling bling then he saw some shots a
doctor and you could have had a bad Tigs
noncommittal
helped you with your welfare just a
little you used to hold him down
now he's holding you back and that's the
sound of his wolf eNOS leading the pack
three percent that's what the DNA test
kit told me three percent wolf Venus and
that's why he's leading the pack it's
above average one to two percent is
average and I knew my son was an average
three percent wolf that's basically like
him making the honor roll you know I'm
so proud if you're looking to know your
dog's breed you want to know if they're
at risk for genetic health conditions
the embark DNA test kits screens for
over a hundred and seventy genetic
health conditions and they help your vet
provide the best medical care for your
dog it is the best in class dog DNA test
kit the number one highest rated by
customers and it is developed by PhDs
and veterinarians for your dog it's the
most accurate breed identification on
the market embark is more than twice as
precise as the next competitor so if you
have a dog you definitely need this or
if you know someone who has a dog it's a
genius gift right now embark has an
exclusive offer you can't get anywhere
else
go to embark vet calm right now use the
promo code toast to save 15% off your
dog DNA test kit
so that's visit embark vet comm eeehm
VAR k ve t.com and use the promo code
toast to see 15% off your dog DNA test
kit Thank You embark for obviously
sponsoring the show but also like
letting me know what precious gem of a
man my dog is right and obviously like
that your kit doesn't come with the song
written for you but you can use the
information to write your own song let's
see there that's important disclaimer
next up love is blind gets renewed for
two more seasons Netflix is outlandish
in popular reality dating series which
follows couples who get engaged before
they even lay eyes on each other is
coming back for a second and third
season in the streaming service
announced on Tuesday while season one
took place in Atlanta season two will be
in Chicago the season 3 location has not
been revealed I love that they're still
doing it by city like I think part of
the reason why they had any success was
because they found people who live in
the same city it's that's part of the
reason why it's tell me bachelor couples
don't make it like nobody wants to move
like they don't have to worry about that
which I love and I think Chicago is a
fabulous City it's genuinely one of my
favorites and I think that this is great
I'm looking forward to now that it's so
popular like I'm afraid that they're not
gonna get the same quality of people
that they got another reason why the
show was so successful is I didn't
really feel like everyone on there was a
thirst monster I thought they were
genuinely looking for love is there
still going on a reality show there's
always that element yes so now it's so
popular and by the way they announced
that they were launching a second and
third season and they announced like
enrollment casting if you want to sign
up if you live in Chicago you can and if
you're a toaster you should and then you
need to like you know really get
involved in and engaging it married and
then ask during the pods like what
podcasts do you listen to right and then
you come on the toast with your
significant other and it'll be so
excited yeah I feel like um this is
exciting they also uh renewed the circle
for more seasons but I never watch it i
watch the first episode and I just
couldn't get into it but people said we
would like it so much
whenever now I know honestly like I'm
and it passed and so like if I watch it
now I'd have no one to talk about and
they know who wins it because he Bart
ended I watched up and I found him so
annoying
I agree also it's like this is exciting
that season two was happening but like
they're never they're not gonna be able
to start filming for like six months
yeah new season won't come out for a
year and so
don't want to get too excited yeah call
me in a year yeah I think one of the the
greatest things to come out of this
quarantine is that The Bachelor is not
on and they're supposed to be filming so
like we get so many more weeks without
The Bachelor yeah it's exciting it's
fabulous it's fabulous
there's so much drama over there they're
recasting Matt James doesn't know if
he's going on like I can yeah Oh also I
found out I think from the snitch that
Matt James like when he wasn't going
when they were still gonna film directly
before coronavirus and he wasn't going
on anymore it was because of Tyler's mom
dying and like that was a huge loss for
him he wasn't ready
oh so but now that it's being postponed
he's been able to yeah well if you're
looking for all the bachelor tea the
snatchler has it all she's recapping at
all everything the quarantine house
she's actually really fun any thoughts
about the quarantine crew new episode is
available on iTunes and Spotify hosted
by Margo her co-host is quarantined
elsewhere so she had to do it alone I
think she did a great job it's a solo
snatch it's this solo snatch okay next
story is something that's just brought
like a little bit of joy and light to
you know an otherwise dark situation
the brothers Cuomo Chris Cuomo and
Governor Andrew Cuomo have been teasing
each other on live TV and it's
everything of the sort it's everything
of the sort
so obviously Governor Cuomo has been you
know very big in the news he's been
going on CNN where his brother Chris
Cuomo is a host who is by the way a fox
he's a bit of a snatchler he's a fox
like I need more is he married I don't
know I guess we could find out actually
you know now that I think about it I
don't really obviously I'm not familiar
with like all of Chris Cuomo's work but
now that I'm thinking about him I do
remember seeing a video of him going
viral with fighting with some kids yeah
and was there like a Frank Cuomo like
there was another Cuomo was there I
don't know they've another brother
I don't know obviously the underachiever
so they promo is the governor of New
York and Chris Cuomo his brother has a
big show on CNN he's like a very popular
host so they're really doing quite well
yeah and so they obviously he interviews
him and then they just like roast each
other and tell each other to call their
mom and that one's better at basketball
and like the other needs to clip their
toenails
it's literally it makes me laugh so hard
okay it's fingernails like they're so
funny and you know what it's they're
they're both like actually great actors
because at first I thought they have
like real beef but they obviously don't
it's so cute and so funny and just some
nice levity it is some nice levity and I
think they realize that when they did it
the first time I
she think it was genuine like you call
mom no you yeah and they realize people
liked it so much so now they are hamming
it up and it's it's not there see it's
everything of the sort if you haven't
watched some of the highlights you
should because it's really cute and
they're both like really cute let me
pose a question for you what do you want
if you can cry rather yeah who would you
rather Kris or governor okay
looks wise Kris is very handsome yeah
but like a younger vibe and personality
wise like I'm all in on Governor Cuomo
these days and whether he's a powerful
man and then I would need the first lady
of New York right and he's wielding his
power for good like he's really
everyone's talking about it and by the
way I know like no one was actually
listening to the actual interview of him
and Kris but he actually said something
brilliant and he was like Kris said you
know Andrew people are really commending
you like for how you're handling this
and he's like listen like this is how I
do my job every day just more people are
watching and I'm glad that people are
like it but I'm not doing anything
different
I'm just being the governor and people
are happy with it and more eyeballs are
watching because New York is the
epicenter of coronavirus in America and
it's so true like he's really been a
fabulous leader and a lot of people are
wondering if he's gonna run for
president and he 100% has my vote and I
would joke a lot that I wish I voted for
Miranda Hobbes instead of Cuomo which I
voted homo not Cuomo but I'm actually
really grateful I voted well actually I
didn't vote but I voted in my heart for
Cuomo ya know he's doing a really great
job and I think his I didn't I guess
I've never heard him talk before but
like he's so funny and he's a gangster
I'm candid you know he's not your
average politician I had no clue because
he's handsome too like I know that's not
supposed to be important but you know
I'm we watching Sex in the City and
Samantha says it's very important no
one's gonna take a world leader
seriously if they're ugly
totally also he was the one Governor
Cuomo who was in a relationship with
Sandra Lee from the Food Network oh my
god yes that is so true super God and
it's when he was governor and so she was
our first lady for a while single um
tickets let's see Andrew Cuomo
relationship I feel like as the governor
like you need a first lady yeah you do
maybe like ever someone will see him on
the news now and be like oh my god that
I think I don't think he's ever had a
problem like catching the ladies you
know but he's so busy right now can you
go from governor to president I feel
like you have to be senator first right
I mean the rules are out the door now
it's so true so you can go from just
billion to president I absolutely love
Governor Cuomo and I love Chris and I
just I think Chris has a wife so
unfortunately this who'd you rather is
really irrelevant no my ultimate answer
is I would rather the governor who but
what about you I think that I would
rather Chris because first of all he's
just cute or second of all there are a
lot of limitations it's like what you
can do as governor like you have to be
professional and like if you're the
first lady like you have to be held
accountable
whereas honestly Chris Cuomo yes he
works in news but he's really just a
celebrity yeah and like you're a media
type and like you could live that life
yeah and by the way I bet CNN pays big
bucks for a star like that yeah not for
like just a low-level you know
on-the-ground reporters it could like
put you into the show well of course no
maybe we could have CNN acquire tnan oh
yeah yeah just be good to be at the CNN
headquarters like see what's going on
you know maybe write a few articles
about myself you know
we'll say same way people are sharing
some interesting information about
Andrew Cuomo's kids oh wow are they high
achievers themselves as well so he was
married oh my god it gets crazier Andrew
Cuomo was married to Kerry Kennedy for
13 years so his kids are Kennedy's so
did the Cuomo last name they've the coma
last night but they got the Kennedy
blood and Academy spirit honestly I
think I would prefer to have the Kennedy
last name in the Cuomo blood and spirit
but it's how do you agree but they also
have the Cuomo Clemence course of course
of course they have Cuomo and community
Mary Julie did they have any kids I
don't think they got married I think
they were just in in a relationship what
are we such like a bah-bah boost I love
that yeah he's a man about town he's the
definition of a man about town the town
he's about is Albany which like isn't
that fabulous but I'm sure he frequents
you know Manhattan in the Hamptons
Albany's pretty fabulous I just want to
say I went to Albany and I had the most
fabulous time literally I stayed at this
hotel
it was the Renaissance I wasn't sure if
I was just like so tired from all the
shitty hotels had been at and the
Renaissance appeared to be a palace but
me and Margo regard that as the best
hotel we ever stayed at and the most
beautiful city literally looks like
Washington DC before all the people
showed up like it's there's nobody there
and it's so clean and it's royal it's
actually beautiful I take back what I
said maybe I should move to Albany I
don't think so but it's a farm gem and
vibe not to that was any like yeah
sounds lovely okay I hit up Governor
Cuomo yeah okay cool are you ready find
out like what rich neighborhood he lives
in and
trait yeah are you ready for a fit and
final story I think so because it's a
story I chose for CEO okay um and he's
not here but I think that you could tell
him when you get home or he's probably
watching at home okay any think he'll be
really excited about it okay because the
next Cadbury well the next Cadbury bunny
is a two-legged dog named Lieutenant Dan
Cadbury announced its next man had very
chocolatey Cadbury chocolate his head up
if you can watch a show last week
literally I was traumatized because I
was walking Theo like to pee and he
accidentally picked up a Cadbury egg and
you know chocolate is toxic for dogs I
was literally wrestling with him on the
street with like this full Cadbury egg I
don't even know where he found it I
literally got covered in chocolate it
was traumatizing so they have a new low
they have a new mascot they have a new
mascot it's a two-legged dog and he's a
good boy and his name is Lieutenant Dan
that is such a cute name these words
from Forrest Gump's who like a dog with
a pair of bunny ears on and Cadbury
bunny it's kind of rude name now that I
think about it like Lieutenant Dan was
known for so much more he was a war hero
you're obviously gonna only remember him
for the fact that he had to amputate
legs
this dog might be a war here or two you
never know it's true you never know
where someone comes from the company
announced on Facebook after watching the
morning toast and seeing how much dogs
like cut berry eggs that the two-legged
dog Lieutenant Dan has been named the
next Cadbury bunny he received more than
200,000 votes beating other contestants
including Consuela the llama dilly barb
Dan whatever now call me crazy it was a
fan vote of competition I love it was
not easy
I loved audience interaction I love that
Cadbury is really diving in and you know
engaging with their community but call
me crazy you know she didn't the Cadbury
bunny be a bunny well they do have
Lieutenant Dan in bunny ears and I think
it's you know their cross-genre across
the whole animal world like I get that
brands are like desperate in these times
to like be relevant and you know be
funny and have good marketing campaigns
but to me this is just totally missing
the mark like a Cadbury bunny like call
me old-fashioned you know I am very
traditional but I do think it should be
a bunny I guess and I just I feel like
you're being so close-minded I don't
understand just like a dog being the
Cadbury bunny like it's physically
impossible
I don't know this picture is pretty
convincing it's just so silly like I'm
totally empathetic to the fact that like
brands are struggling right now I feel
like the Cadbury one er is trying to
reach new animals and trying to reach
new audiences and
they know obviously they have the proof
that dogs like Cadbury eggs it's true
and so they were just putting all that
information together and giving us
Lieutenant Dan well I'm really happy for
Lieutenant Dan and obviously like he's
been living out his wildest dreams and
that's all you can really want for a to
like a dog yeah I think do you think
that if he had known about the
competition sooner like Theo could have
totally swept yeah but to be honest like
I wouldn't let him join such a dumb
competition like I don't believe in the
message behind the competition therefore
I don't think I would let my son at
participate but what if it's what he
really wanted you and this was his dream
and this was what's gonna make him
happiest that's a good point the thing
is is that I know Theo and I know that
he would like this is honestly beneath
him but everyone has to start somewhere
no it doesn't like commercial deals just
haven't been rolling in for him like
they used to
you know what he's fine he's retired
he's in he's a husband and he's grateful
he wasn't ever and ever was okay I mean
I think he could do great things still
you know because I think the senior dogs
need to be represented as well but
that's just the anti a just in me we are
going to dive into our recap segment
before Deer toasters our recap segment
is brought to you by Charlotte Tilbury
with 27 years in the beauty industry
Charlotte has been responsible for the
creation of countless iconic beauty
styles and she is regarded as a
visionary and trendsetter in 2013
Charlotte Tilbury changed the face of
global beauty industry with the launch
of her makeup and skincare collection
decoding her traditionally closed-door
VIP expertise giving women and men the
tools to be the most beautiful versions
of themselves
she believes that everyone at every age
deserves to look and feel like the most
beautiful version of themselves through
the power of makeup her makeup
collection is iconic in many ways but
her pillow-talk collection which is a
part of her makeup collection is
probably the biggest lipstick on the
planet the pillow-talk collection is
Charlotte's best-selling globally adored
nude pink shade that's on everyone's
lips literally every celebrity wears it
to every red carpet it's the little
black dress of makeup it's versatile and
dreamy it is the perfect pink nude shade
to bring out the most beautiful version
of you the proof is in the numbers
America loves pillow talk and it was the
number one lipstick in the u.s. in 2019
and now as of January there are more
pillow talk shades Charlotte is
expanding her iconic pillow talk
collection to include medium and intense
shades of each pillow talks product
product so there's now a lip liner a
lipstick a blusher and an eye palette
the adored iconic shade is now available
to flatter everyone's natural beauty and
can also be used to dial up your look
for every mood from day two desk to date
two beyond
or to your living room during the
quarantine if you're just feeling like
being pretty because that can really
affect your mood if you want to shop the
iconic pillow talk collection do so it's
shoppable directly from Charlotte
Tilbury calm as well as a free-standing
beauty wonderland at the Grove in LA and
it's also sold at most north drum and
Sephora's in North America visit
Charlotte Tilbury calm for the store
finder Thank You Charlotte Tilbury for
being fabulous and for sponsoring
today's episode sign on so let's recap
um
sleepover I actually wrote down a bunch
of notes because I had a lot of thoughts
let's just start with the cast okay
the cast was just more iconic like every
time someone stepped out the door brie
Larson as Liz Wright Sara Paxton who is
just like an eye kind of mind like a
hero aquamarine would also be a great
movie because I loved that movie it
really would be a gem Dench
Shane Lynch and Jeff Garland right Evan
Peters advocators was like well he used
to bother me when I would watch it as a
child but now I just have a new respect
for him and like he was just like such a
stand-up guy and he was there when you
needed him like yeah and he won the
dance competition for Sara Paxton and
got back heard her boyfriend and then he
ended up actually like liking him I
don't think never really made sense
because she was such a [ __ ] like she
never really would have given spongebob
but then in the beginning like I really
felt for her when like her boyfriend was
just like not being contentious I mean
that is technically assault yeah well no
soon she went from like a salt to a
sleepover and like of course she was
being in a bad mood yeah I know that's
true like that'll do it to you but you
know it's interesting how things have
changed because like that was textbook
assault and for a movie about kids like
that today would literally never be in a
movie there were also a bunch of things
that like ate didn't age well like Nancy
are you gonna see the diet pill company
because they obviously didn't work which
was such a [ __ ] nasty comment oh my
god nasty another star Steve Carell
right it was just little non-stop stars
nonsense stars here are the things that
really bothered me about the movie okay
some of the logistics made no sense okay
so Sarah Paxton was dating a high
schooler they were they were in the
middle so they were in eighth grade they
were 14 they were in eighth grade and
she was talking about hooking up having
sex okay here's here's what it is
Yancey 14 year old can drive and I can
oh but that was the other thing so Oh
totally but then it was like so he's
driving we don't know what age he has in
high school probably 17 so it's like 17
year old and a 14 year old that's in
her boyfriend oh no but he was on the JV
squad so he's probably two years older
than her
okay JV that's true that's probably a
sophomore at best some more villages
accept bother me when Jane Lynch left
the house with her girlfriends it was
dark out they had a full sleepover they
froze their bras they didn't makeup
manicurists did the website and the
dance ended at midnight mhm so you're
telling me in the four hours they were
able to have a full-blown sleepover meet
up with sara paxton have that meeting
with sara paxton do all of the things on
the activity and still spend time at the
dance for to win the homecoming queen to
do the dance contest and literally four
hours no I agree and also like they had
just graduated from middle school so we
know it was June and the days are really
long so it doesn't even get dark until
like nine three hours
the logistics was really Bobby and then
also like Jane Lynch is gonna go and
phone home and she's able to get home on
a skateboard like how close oh he wears
the club around the corner yeah and then
when the treehouse is coming down in the
backyard and they're like screaming oh
yeah Jeff Garlin he might be oblivious
but he's not deaf no no but he was the
best character oh my god imagine like
Jeff Garlin it's a script for a movie
it's like you're gonna be fixing the
water the whole time no he'd literally
plays the same role he's the same as the
dad and Goldberg yeah plays the same
role whatever but he's amazing if it
ain't broke don't fix it except if you
need a new water filtration system the
other part about the movie that really
bothered me was first of all how
dangerous this whole thing was like ganz
he barely knows how to drive there no
waste
you mean Yancy Musk with her electric
car Yancy is the daughter of elon musk's
that's the backstory that you don't know
and she has one of the first electric
cars in production totally it was a
prototype and then she was the one who
told the Elan like we need to make the
charging cords longer like I'm stay for
longer and maybe bigger see its butt so
when I think about literally how
dangerous this whole thing was they were
driving without seatbelts with someone
who barely knew how to drive four people
in the front seat they crashed they went
to a club and met with someone on the
internet and four saw this teacher you
telling me got through college and made
himself into a teacher but he didn't
recognize his own student wearing
sunglasses
yeah I don't know and he was wearing his
glasses ya know and that whole scene was
so inappropriate like he'll I got it and
like she let him go on with flirting
with her it was so in her being also
like that guy was cute like yeah he
doesn't need you shouldn't be so hard
but show
literally ended up flirting with his
fourteen-year-old and he wasn't feeling
more inappropriate about it like yeah I
mean that whole scene was so weird but
then the whole concept of her meeting up
with someone from the internet was so
dangerous so dangerous and then stealing
from a not okay it's it's breaking and
entering into Steve's house and then
stealing the paw Patrol or whatever that
thing was called like I know it's yeah
and it was a like britain's like those
mannequins like someone's gonna have to
clean that up
oh yeah no the whole thing was just so
reckless and dangerous and now watching
it as an adult I was really surprised in
her actions I was disappointed in her
and then you know it also didn't make
sense like Jane Lynch was this really
really strict mom and then she knows
that her daughter's broke all the rules
and then she still gives heard the
doorknob yeah but I think it's because
like she was just proud of her car
making the rules but like getting home
safe and being responsible ya know like
get you a girl that can do both she
doesn't want like a loser daughter he's
upstairs all night yeah that's true he
doesn't need a lock on her door because
she's not doing anything you see when
Alexa Vega was in the shower and she saw
Steve spa-like that is also textbook
assaults like Sonia I guess yeah that's
true it's no it's um it's like people
like did you see what I posted on my
story that's teas ankles way because
this is I'm gonna show you my story
really quickly cuz this is a scene that
since I was a child like has always
triggered me and just makes my own
ankles like feel very vulnerable is it
when he steps out of the car no no it's
when he takes his boxers off look at his
Achilles heel it's like so prominent and
it makes it used to like I used to have
like visions of someone just like
slicing into my head by the way I
totally feel and by the way 92% of
people said that it made their own
ankles feel vulnerable yeah I agree I
must've been looking at my phone during
that part of the movie but I remember it
from when we were you know but like when
I was a kid like and then I can feel the
scene coming up and like my ankle
started taking so better like I that was
something that's like you know when
you're a kid in your like weird fears of
course like Steve's Achilles heel like
made me like just feel so like and so
vulnerable about my ankles like someone
could just slice the bone at any time
maybe that's why you've always had like
a real connection to Taylor Swift's
lyric you're my Achilles heel
agreed that's probably why another thing
I wrote down when what's Alexa Vegas
character's name Julie Julie Julie Julie
Court game hey you guys remember Julie
porky oh yeah Julie quirky I forgot
thank you so wait that was real okay
when she tried to get to the dance and
the girl wouldn't let her in with
tickets and she thought it would be good
to insult the girl to let her into the
dance she goes to Roasters I will be you
in four years unless I get into that
dance really that girl seems lovely you
know she's a great job in student
council she's definitely going to a good
college like she's probably like [ __ ]
this dude I think that would be
effective she I mean it was but like
literally how [ __ ] rude you meet
lunch by the dumpsters I will be you in
four years [ __ ] rude now to me the
the movie has one fatal flaw hmm they
get home they go to sleep Alexa Vega
wakes up with curly hair and shows up to
the pancake breakfast with a blowout
now do I doubt that she might have blown
her hair out between waking up and going
with pancake breakfast no it's very
possible but you're telling me that she
decided to show up to the dance with
curly yeah when she had the ability to
blow her she had Jesus capability the
whole time and we had to watch a movie
of her like messy messy and she she has
like drive our level skills and you know
maybe if she had shown up with that
bouncy fresh blowout to the club maybe I
can understand how her teacher wouldn't
recognize her
I completely completely agree just to
believe that like she'd be running
around in this sweaty red dress with her
sweaty curly hair and steam would be
attracted to that like I don't buy it
but if she had her fence
blow out I could see how Steve would
think she was this mature woman not some
child yeah no I totally agree
it stood out to me as well those were
all my notes oh also like you know who's
like a really weird character who like
really contributed nothing except like
the redheaded girl yeah except she made
the dress from like drab to fab that's
true but like all of her lines were like
syringes and like she was like aren't
you that stacy couldn't come
Yancy's like why because she was mom
only let her invite three girls like Oh
Marie what is her name
anytime do I even know ID at any time
like something happened like she would
have the line that's like you know takes
like something just like lame like some
summarizing what we just saw I do think
she played one important role and I
remember as a kid thinking that when
they were in the mannequin store and
they were pretending to be mannequins
she was the only girl who actually
looked like I'm adding because she's so
pale and pasty like I actually felt like
that girl could actually be a mannequin
because her hair looks fake her skin is
so white like she literally just like
was frozen yeah so that is what she was
important um also I need to discuss one
thing because the toasters were saying
that Nancy's speaker moving boyfriend
looks like memes and by the way there
are a hundred percent right and I just
wish I had it I wonder if I would have
thought that if I hadn't read it right
before I saw the scenes right um because
it really really looks oh my god that is
one of the funniest things ever I
actually found Yancey on Instagram she
follows me and she did not marry the
speaker guy which is very upsetting but
she did recently get married to someone
cute yeah when the band was like this is
didn't Yancey from the speaker moving
guy but by the way the music from the
movie is so iconic and I was having
flashbacks like I remember I don't know
what band was playing but I remember
like I loved that song and then I would
listen to the bands like other songs and
I even remember being so inspired by the
way Sara Paxton was dancing at the dance
just like having a blast
while she danced and I think that's
where I might have gotten my dance moves
like that dress that she wore the whole
time was so like on oh my god yeah of
course she gets look fabulous the whole
time she was supposed to go to the dance
yeah it was really just a fabulous movie
in age well ever have thought that of
all the icons in the movie all the icons
that Liz Larson would win the Oscar Oh
actually when I was watching it I was
totally understanding that she was
actually did have a big role
but she played the role very well
because she was like that older kid
exactly really seriously I'm outside
with the Beamer
honk-honk how they had those phones that
were also walkie-talkies was that a real
thing back in the day oh I don't know
and it said where would listen Sarah's
parents you know I don't know they just
like didn't love them as much maybe um
do me the worst character was her
brother oh yeah he used to always bother
me first all those pizzas looked so good
I was so hungry when I was watching the
movie like oh my god what I would have
gone for a slice of Domino's Pizza yeah
um but then he really had Julie
Courtney's back yeah he did big time but
he was also bribing her like she had to
bribe him yeah not for free no but it's
like siblings like I would cover you if
you need me to cover you
I don't think Julie would like she seems
like she's a good sister it seems like
sheisty is she was also really talking
down to her brother like from the moment
the movie started like he dropped out of
politics obviously going through
something sympathy and he's obviously
like not a hundred percent like the way
he just like would write like he was
just weird know if she just wasn't like
he's sympathetic she wasn't in
empathetic way she was like so hard on
her best friend for like having to move
oh yeah like I think your choice oh my
god that was so silly that was Jackie I
blame you oh my god like so rough so
rough um really like totally unrelated
but when you were talking about pizza we
ordered Hill Stone last night and I know
that people are really I'm skeptical of
ordering but I do think it's important
if you can to support local businesses
and we ordered so much food from
hellstone it came so fast so perfect
really protected the delivery woman
called she said I'm leaving it with the
doorman she didn't come up they do no
contact delivery so if you're looking
for somewhere and you're in the delivery
zone of a hellstone which in other
cities is called Houston's
I highly recommend Saxby Viet restaurant
he always goes and picks it up and they
actually don't deliver usually but now
they're doing two livery yeah um and I
think he was like so excited but I was
already cooking my mushroom pasta when
he found out and so I was like great you
can have it tomorrow
yeah because you're eating while you're
eating my chowder tonight
okay let's also recap been upon Broyles
even though like it's so painful it's
painful but I had a lot of different
thoughts about it yeah well when she sat
down with Raquel looked so snatched
Laurie no [ __ ] sickening like my
stomach and even our Kelly held her own
it was a beautiful it was a beautiful
vibe to teddy vibe was
point like they were in a pink like you
know coffee shop a shop it was so cute I
thought the conversation was actually so
sweet
except when Raquel was like listen you
can insult my character but don't insult
my intelligence like why is one
different than the other no totally and
then like Wallace said one thing she was
like that means so much obviously
Wallace had more than that yeah um and I
really liked light when they were gonna
be on the same side and like have
James's back in the way that it's just
like totally turned at Toms extra party
um made me sad he's like pointing but
that's just Raquel like she refuses to
see the Fault in James when it's like by
the way you can love someone and still
know what's wrong with them if nobody's
perfect she refuses to be called out and
if they really are both like teaming up
to help James stay sober in the
beginning it's so hard you need people
around you and he need to be held
accountable so if people are saying that
he went to a party in the hills and
drank and she didn't go to the party in
the hills why is that so hard for her to
say outright he went to a party in the
hills and drank they said that he went
to a party in Hills and everyone was
getting really [ __ ] up there was they
didn't show us at least any evidence
that he had drank but no no they didn't
have footage from it but that he did
know but he didn't even see that he said
it was really crazy everyone was
drinking they never said I saw James
take a drink I saw a yes but so you
should be concerned with someone who's a
weak sober go to a party where people
are getting [ __ ] up that's not a place
for a person who's just newly so we're
yeah I would agree with that but like
still at I I'm gonna try and give him
the benefit of the doubt because
Miguel's reaction was just unreasonable
no but like if someone came to you
especially a former foe and like started
swinging accusations about Ben I would
pop off even if they wound up being
right I'm still popping on yeah but even
if two days before I had sat down with
this person we decided we were gonna
like be on a champ and I would still
won't help em I would still be skeptical
and then they're gonna come to me at a
party and with all these starting with
the drinking but all this stuff about
Logan in the past and I don't work he'll
actually really held her own
yeah you know I'm ya know I really just
can't say I'm novice Lila at la langue
I'm write or die but I'm taking her side
because I just can't stand Raquel yeah I
just I don't know why now I just want
Raquel and James to like succeed well
it's because we are now nine months in
the future and we know that so I guess
if I didn't know that now I'd be
watching this like you're probably
skeptical I'd be like I thought you were
done before my dad died yeah that's what
I'd say wow you done did die but so
powerful they had their memorial for dog
which
I actually thought was pretty funny and
when Tom said well I mean when Tom
Schwartz got choked up like I kind of
felt that you know like how we used to
run around the grass like pets are so
personal and I know you don't have one
so you might not be able to understand
I'm a pet for like what was it like a
month but now he's a storyline and we're
having a pool party at a public pool to
celebrate a lizard named dog and I think
are things really so bad no but they
just need excuses to get to go pay so
like find a better excuse yeah no that
was a cell to like fit dream machine
awaz you know living for being the
communicator between Christie she was
living for like everyone giving her
permission to like do it everyone yeah
you know and I liked that role for her
cuz I think she did a really good and
important job because arguments had
institude but there's something I need
to talk about mhm mhm and it's Tom
Sandoval and how he's unbelievably a bit
of control
yeah like three second scene where he's
like getting frustrated with his dad not
opening the door correctly where he's
walking in on stilts and like his dad's
like getting in the way if he's like big
entrance where he could be like a big
loser at his losery party like the loser
a theme was just like so interesting
yeah he to me is the worst character on
the show and will inevitably inevitably
be the downfall of the show um and it's
frustrating because I actually really
like Ariana but she always and
rightfully so like defends her man when
he's usually wrong and that just makes
me like disagree with her on all fronts
when I actually think she's like really
smart and could be really like funny and
interesting on the show she wasn't being
bogged down by the ego that is her
boyfriend even when Tom's animals not
fighting with people just like his
presence this season what it feels like
to me is that he's being so heavy-handed
about like sort of branding himself as
being extra that he's trying to like
develop el uno set himself up to become
like to come out with a costume line or
something like he's just like laying it
on so thick when it's like when I think
of Tom sand of all I don't think of like
Stillson being extra normally I just
think of like having a big ego and I
don't know you know I on by the way it's
like how Stassi is really branded
herself it's like the basic [ __ ]
because we have eight seasons of her
like being basic drinking Aperol spritz
like I think he sees he's I definitely
think out of all them like he's the most
competitive and always looks up like the
other cast mates are doing business-wise
and they wrote the cocktail book which
already took them like the entire series
to do and I think that he's like looking
over her shoulder like I what other
people are doing and Stas he's having a
lot of success with like branding
herself like with the podcast at or a
book as base
he's like I'm gonna be extra now it's
like just like a word thing ya know I
hates a word like is really coming
across and it's bothering me because of
how like authentic things happen he's my
least favorite person on the show and
even before he was out of control and he
was like an integral part of the
storyline I never really liked him but
Todd like the dynamic is weird because
Tom Schwartz I want to say he's closer
with Tom Sanibel than he is with Jax but
he really is firmly in the middle and
Jax and Tom Sanibel don't get along so
the and I think the group is closer with
Jax and Brittany yeah than they are with
Tom and Ariana so like stanton was kind
of like on the edge but Schwartz is like
kind of the shorts is kind of on the
edge yeah the dynamics are really weird
because there are a couple dynamics like
Ariana and Tom are actually really close
with Tom and Katie but Ariana and Katie
like aren't that close like the couple
dynamics and the single person dynamics
are all really interesting between the
boys and the girls yeah um
Dana and Max stuff like makes me sad
because I just want Dana to win and I
hate that like Danica got to her but I
just love that now like Danica is like
being put on the spot for being a [ __ ]
starter I can't stand her she's actually
my least favorite new character and like
when Raquel told her that Lala was
reached out to her and like you could
literally see in her eyes it was like
Madonna had reached out like and then
she also was giving Raquel advice to
like not trust Lala because I God forbid
like like magic mark Alyn Lala became
friends and Donna becomes even more
irrelevant but it's like it was just
like yeah why are you on my show Danica
has watched what read one to many text
books about how to be a reality star
she's just doing all of the tactics to
make sure she's a mainstay and yeah from
ten years ago yeah I refuse to give her
my attention like oh she's a suspended
manager that's all she's ever gonna be
you can't put her on my TV screen yeah
other than that it was like a boring
episode and it just wasn't in the mood I
need to talk about the witches of WeHo
dynamic because it is unbelievably
interesting because you know when it
comes to the card or drama I'm pretty
much on Stassi and Katie side and they
see what they're saying and I and I
totally see it but what I said about the
Pinterest and the t-shirts those mean so
unbelievably mean especially because
everyone has been like supportive of
James a wearing James May they go to the
launch events and it's like
they're all supportive of other people's
brains like when Katie wanted to launch
a blog they all went to that event yet
they're always supportive of the other
person's business venture and it's like
so that's what you really think of what
she's doing like that's such [ __ ]
and also like Kristin's barely on the
show and she still finds a way to like
stay relevant write a book have a
t-shirt line and like have a little
income and job in life for herself
whereas Katie like is one of the longest
standing cast members probably makes the
most from the show and does the least no
and I thought it was most interesting
with the witches of WeHo wine because I
get that they're not like a sisterhood
and the whole brand but they have a
contract and like it is on everyone to
do their part post on social and just
because you're not feeling Christian
doesn't mean you should be able to get
out on your responsibilities to the
business and even though like the
friendship isn't as strong like do you
like the wine yes then sell the line I'm
not that it's not that deep where it's
like I can't sell something that I don't
believe in totally like the wine do you
drink the wine and sell the wine and I
don't know if the wine is still being
sold right now but like Stassi and our
confessionals being like I can't sell
something I don't believe in like that
just sucks to anyone who bought it like
who because you don't I mean like yeah
it just feels so an authentic and if
they're still selling it and stassi's on
the show saying that she gets doesn't
believe in it like who's gonna buy it
it's like you don't drink the wine to
like form a sisterhood like you drink
the wine cuz you like how it tastes and
if you made the wine then you like how
it tastes then you should be able to
sell it at least until your contractor
yeah but I do totally agree with like
Stassi has so much going on she's on a
whole nother level like she's obviously
got involved in the [ __ ] when before all
this happens yeah or like maybe it was a
great contract they had like a really
good situation and it was a no brainer
because all they do is drink wine like I
don't know what I've done to you but
I'll take a premium Pinot Grigio um but
I do understand like and maybe it at the
outset it was good but like working with
Katie who clearly doesn't contribute
much to the wine and then works with
Kristin who she's not even friends with
it's like I'm over here doing all of
these things why am I wasting my time
with all this
I completely understand it but business
is business you guys slip in on the deal
and you got a junior responsibilities
yeah and it sucks for sure because she
has so much going on like I I really
felt so badly for Kristin and also when
Chris Moews like you guys are my sisters
like blah blah blah and cuz Tasi was
like we're not sisters we're not sisters
anymore it's like that's not how sisters
work but you like have you know this but
like you're always going to be my sister
but every Kristin felt like we're going
through bad times but we're always
sisters right and so if you're not
sisters anymore it means that you
absolutely never work because if that
was your sister she would always be your
sister that's actually a very valid
point so that was really sad
and like and hurtful and when I just
felt really badly for Kristen meet you I
mean I've been on Kristen's side just
because I have like a lot of empathy for
her but when it comes to the business
stuff I actually thought she was right
too like in the Carter stuff look she's
wrong and being she was also right about
the facts that's like she has it at
least a little bit more going on than
Katie like why can't you pick up some of
the slack yeah and it's just because
Katie's not feeling Kristen which is not
a reason not to do your responsibility
in a business you have to separate the
two business and friendship you got to
do what you got to do for the business
you have a contract do it yeah yes but I
think that conversation was wildly
interesting because they all have so
much going on outside of the show and
the show sometimes makes us really still
think that they're waiters and
waitresses and doesn't acknowledge the
fact that like Stassi Katie you're not
even a waiter yeah but you know what I
mean like they refuse to acknowledge
that these people are celebrities
they're rich like so they're doing a
better job now and then suddenly we know
about stassi's book and we know she's a
New York Times best seller and like we
see the houses and so we know it's not
and we know that people have businesses
like this season they're really like
leaning into it but not they're done
pretending that they're just right so in
this conversation like moves us forward
in the sense that they're like now
bringing their business ventures as
storylines but this is the first
business venture between multiple people
across the show and it's obviously not
going well no it's it's not um so that's
our Vanderpump rules recap and now we're
gonna dive into tear toasters oh yeah
but let's also assign our next toast
movie of the day what do we decide on
homecoming okay Netflix documentary
special I haven't seen it yet and I
really want to watch it I saw it a while
ago and only once and I feel like that I
just want to switch it up and like watch
something fun also a lot of the dance
moves are going but I want to talk right
now and I just feel like we should all
be participating yeah I just think one
like I'm what I've wanted to watch it so
it's a perfect thing to do today I love
a concert DVD to me it's like the
absolute combination of everything that
I love TV and music so check it's
available on Netflix so dear toasters is
our advice segment if you want to get
involved
dear toasters at gmail.com is the email
you can write in to we always keep it
anonymous and we're covering everything
from quarantine weddings whatever so
always keep it anonymous dear toasters
at gmail.com here's our first one
dear toasters to be productive during
quarantine times these quarantine times
I've helped my parents clean out their
house during our cleaning I found a
photocopy of a note stuck inside a
folder the note was from 20 years ago
almost to the exact days
so freaky from my dad to a woman named
Heather not my mom's name in the note my
dad states that he sad they couldn't
hook up the previous night but I'm not
sure he means it in a sexual way he goes
on to tell the story of a woman he
witnessed at a bar who slipped off her
wedding ring and danced with other men
he says he was critical of her but a
female colleague shrugged and told him
that some people just want to know that
they are so attractive the big thing in
the letter is that he signs off a simple
thank-you and to the lingering visual of
tight shorts and then he signs his name
I have no idea what to make of this
letter my parents have been married for
35 years and my mom is like my best
friend I can hardly look at my dad right
now even though I'm not sure if it's
incriminating but who writes a letter to
someone of the opposite sex that is not
your spouse or family and what is the
reference to a visual of tight shorts I
wish I never found this letter what do i
do should I talk to my siblings about
this and taint their view of our dad as
well should I tell my mom and cause
drama over something that happened 20
years ago what if she knows since the
note was photocopy should I talk to my
dad about it this sounds so
uncomfortable please help sincerely a
toaster who knows way too much or way
too little how do you know that the note
is from 20 years ago
it has date on it so who [ __ ] cares
oh yeah I mean um I'm so sorry that you
found that a night like you have to
think about this but I would do
absolutely nothing 20 years ago is such
a long time ago like either your mom
knows and they've made peace with it
your mom doesn't know and she doesn't
need to know like I would just even
though it's painful keep it to yourself
they've been married for 35 years to
bring up something from 20 years ago
that your mom might know about it's just
none of your business and just like let
it go try and forget about it but even
if your dad did something wrong 20 years
ago like even if you knew for certain
like your dad cheated on your mom 20
years ago and your mom doesn't know yeah
and I would not tell her no of course
not what are you gonna break up the
family from something from 20 years ago
was he faithful now yes and that's good
and you know what if he was like such a
serial cheater over 35 years there would
be something more than a letter from 20
years ago
yeah so I think I just gotta and maybe
it was photocopied 20 years ago but the
original when you write a letter you
write the date on it like you date it oh
I guess yeah whatever okay next up dear
toasters I would like to preface this
with the fact that I come from a large
family five girls to boys and same
parents my older brother has been dating
the same girl for five years and they
got engaged it's December and recently
moved in together my brother is a great
guy but very headstrong unfortunately so
is his fiancee
she owns him and he could never do
anything without her approval she
managed to date him for five years and
have zero relationship with me and many
sisters who live just down the street
my brother has recently told me that I
cannot come over without her being at
his place so I now cannot see my older
sister my older brother without his
fiancee being present she's controlling
makes him come to bat for her every time
which is fine but I seriously believe
that she hates my family and wants him
to have a relationship with us and it's
working Claudia and Jackie went to Baiju
I'm worried he's gonna keep brushing off
what I say and make it to the altar
another detail my brother is very
Catholic and divorce will not be an
option I must save him with love a sad
toaster oh that's kind of sad um I would
ask your brother if you could have a
talk with her like kind of try to find
out where she's coming from yeah because
you want to know why I like I actually
feel like this and it's much more
dramatic but I feel like this letter
like could have been written about me
because I'm very controlling especially
as it comes to my house like of course
anyone can come over but like I'm like
then if your family's gonna come over
like I just need to know about it I
would like to be there like I'm very
personal about my house sometimes it's
like I want to clean up I want to make
sure something's not out like I'm [ __ ]
as it's thought of like having my
in-laws come over when I haven't like
given the house the okay
like it gives me anxiety and like
actually totally feel that so I feel
like of course the way you see it it's
like that this girl hates you and by the
way I have a very very good relationship
with Ben's whole family and I don't
think that Ben's sister could write a
letter like this but I am the outside
you can make these a demon i'm totally
controlling especially as it come to my
house as it comes to visitors like so i
feel like i'm more empathetic to baby
like she might be miss reading some of
the the signals like people are just
weird about different things and this
girl just might be weird about her house
and like I am very controlling and Ben
has just come to accepted that this is
life so I I think yeah sit down with the
sister yes she might be like very
private she might be introverted like
maybe you feel like she hasn't worked
hard enough at having a relationship
with you but there's also seven of you
like that's really overwhelming oh yeah
there is a million different things I
would try and like understand where
she's coming from before jumping to
conclusions that she's like corrupting
her brother and and it's all these bad
things yes maybe she just it's like very
private or it has anxiety and you know
doesn't want people in her house when
she's not there I can I can empathize
when you look at it from that way it's
not so crazy when you look at it from
your way it's like oh wow she's
controlling and she's gonna take your
brother and run
but there's definitely a truth somewhere
in the middle this is always what we say
during to your toasters like perspective
is everything yeah cuz I could see like
the both people's perspectives so
definitely communication is key here you
know if you brother really is gonna
marry her
your brother obviously likes her so
there's something he must like about her
like why don't you get to know that part
of her yeah I would say I would agree
with that all right our final one hi
girls I'm having a really tough internal
battle I've been in a relationship for
about a year with my boyfriend we went
to college together and now we live in
the same city and we went to school that
we went to school in I've lived in the
city for five years now and grew up just
an hour away
I really how long were they together in
college for they've been together for a
full year part of it is in college and
part of it they graduated and now live
in the same city they went to college in
she grew up an hour away okay
I recently I've been feeling very
complacent and restless in my life and I
want to move I have a friend that lives
in a different state and I want to move
there with her at the end of the summer
when my lease is up I've been there to
visit multiple times and I love it so
much
the catch is I want to do it alone it's
hard because I don't want to break up
with him or leave him but my desire to
leave and start into adventure somewhere
else outweighs my desire to stay in the
same town and settle for this life that
isn't the filling for me I've hinted at
this and he has no desire to leave
truthfully I don't know if I'd want him
to come with me am i a heartless [ __ ]
for wanting to leave my boyfriend behind
and starting to see new places and see
new things should I tell him that if I'm
seriously considering this if I do
decide to do it should I break up with
him before or see how it goes once I
leave break up with I'm so lost I'm
having such an internal battle that I'd
love to hear your advice yeah I think
honestly the selfish thing would be to
drag him along it may make him move if
he doesn't move and you doing the
morning I didn't want to be and then
like you're not even that you don't
sound like you'd be that upset if you
broke up with him selected dragged him
along in a long-distance relationship
like how your loss is like you know what
I feel like
in the long run he'd probably be
grateful that you did it drag this on
for another this isn't a great love
story no you should go move on with your
life a lot of college relationships like
they're they work in college you know
you're in a sorority and fraternity down
the street or bike into each other's
houses we're going to parties and that's
all fun but like real life is much
different so just because the
relationship works in college does not
mean that it should work in the real
world you're obviously unhappy in your
life you sound like a middle-aged woman
and you're only 21 but good on you is
that time to make a big change break up
with him move I don't know about moving
to a city just because you have one
friend there so definitely think that
part through yeah that's gonna come
toxic no and also like what if your
friend leaves tomorrow are you still
happy there so just that all of that
your different options but definitely
make a big change it isn't you
at a great time like a year is yeah a
lot of time like cut your losses get a
fresh start and good on you for like
having the foresight to like see that
like your life could end up like this
and it's just not the life you want not
everyone but I think it's lovely to like
find someone and just by the way that's
not for everyone so if you know and you
have a vision that that's not the life
that you want good for you for having
that sort of insight and cut your losses
it's not like you're ten years in with
two kids and you're realizing this now
like you have everything you have
nothing to lose everything to gain you
get a fresh start I love change I think
change is so exciting and you know what
sorry
the only thing that's constant is change
and I think coronavirus has been so
clear like maybe made that even more
clear you know oh her damn she says when
you think life is getting normal yeah
boom coronavirus damn I'm so hungry
thank you guys so much for your emails
if you want to email us dear toasters at
gmail.com those were good ones and of
course we always keep it anonymous so
you can write about the quarantine you
can write about work stuff business
stuff relationships up wedding stuff we
don't care I'm the weirder the better
some tear toasters at gmail.com and
that's our show for you guys thank you
so much and a swine for listening to the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go by the Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. on YouTube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasts can be found so that's
about it by iTunes stitcher public video
I already cut back to all the places so
ever you listen to podcast find us the
morning shows and leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we love you guys so much we'll
see you tomorrow bye